For almost two millennia,
the Pope has been a figure
of supreme spiritual authority
for Catholics around the world.
But in the late 14th century,
Catholics found themselves
with not one, not two, but three popes.
Where did this plethora of popes
come from?
And who among them was
the genuine article?
The origins of this papal predicament
began in 1296,
when France’s King Philip IV decided
to raise taxes on the Church.
Given the clergy’s political power,
this offended Pope Boniface VIII,
leading him to write the “Unam Sanctam”:
a radical decree asserting the Pope’s
total supremacy over earthly rulers.
But King Philip struck back.
He declared Boniface a heretic and tried
to have him arrested in a violent raid.
Boniface survived the assault,
but died soon after.
And following a short-lived successor,
Pope Clement V was elected in 1305.
A French diplomat seeking peace in the war
between England and his homeland,
Clement wanted to stay close
to the conflict
and escape the demands of Rome.
So in 1309, he moved the seat
of the papacy to Avignon—
a city close to France but owned
by a vassal of the Church.
The papacy remained here
for the terms of seven popes
until the reigning Pope finally returned
to Italy in 1376.
But just several months after his arrival,
he suddenly died.
This shocking development meant a new
pope had to be elected immediately—
and in Rome, where there hadn’t been
a papal election in over 70 years.
The Romans were determined
to elect one of their own
and restore Rome as the seat
of Western Christendom.
Local officials pressured cardinals
to choose an Italian pope,
while rowdy mobs raided the conclave
and plundered the papal wine cellar.
Amidst this chaos, the cardinals elected
the Neapolitan Archbishop of Bari
to become Pope Urban VI.
Initially, Urban was seen
as a safe choice.
But he quickly proved to be a reformer who
sought to limit the cardinal’s finances.
Desperate to maintain
their luxurious lifestyles,
the cardinals declared
the recent election illegitimate,
since it was decided under pressure
from the Roman mob.
They denounced Urban as a usurper
and held a new conclave
to elect Pope Clement VII.
Clement attempted to excommunicate Urban,
but he refused to recognize
the authority of Clement
or his greedy cardinals.
Urban named new cardinals to his court
and entrenched himself in Rome
while Clement and his supporters
returned to Avignon.
The schism had officially begun.
Western Christendom now had two capitals,
Avignon and Rome,
each with their own Pope
and court of cardinals.
As popes from each line died,
their cardinals appointed successors,
continuing the crisis for decades.
This strange situation didn't impact
most ordinary Catholics,
as there were no significant
doctrinal splits.
Instead, the drama played
out in the diplomatic realm.
European rulers were forced
to choose sides,
as both popes vied
for spiritual and political supremacy.
Only a pope had the authority
to call a general council
to officially resolve the issue,
and both sides refused to take this step.
So in 1409, a group of cardinals
from France and Rome
took matters into their own hands.
They claimed that since both
popes were disputed,
cardinals did have the right
to call a council.
And at their gathering these cardinals
deposed the pretenders
and elected a new Pope.
Unfortunately, both Avignon’s Pope
and Rome’s Pope
refused to recognize this council.
So instead of solving the crisis,
the number of popes rose to three.
This unusual arrangement
lasted five more years,
until the Council of Constance in 1417.
Here, the popes from the Roman line
and recently created third line resigned
and agreed to unite the church
under a new Pope—
Martin V.
Undisputed, Martin swiftly excommunicated
the only person still against him—
the Pope of Avignon—
and finally ended the schism
after 39 years.
Today, the church’s official records
say the Roman Line
was always the true papal power.
But regardless of how the schism ended,
its existence proves that even those
who are supposed to be pious
are prone to petty power struggles.